in Britain theory is mail that could be
reportedly because British consumers
prefer voices that convey authority in
other countries series default is female
could that be because some customers
want their automated personal assistance
to embody obedience and subservient
which ever way you look at it artificial
intelligence is not making our
relationship with gender more
intelligent it's helping us to regress
to a time when you could say to your
female assistant ie your housewife
girlfriend or secretary Cortana stop
Cortana is named after a nude female
video game character by the way or Siri
play some music or Alexa what am i doing
today and where you are arguing about
gender equality on the pledge because
how we treat virtual women like you my
dear has real consequences for how we
treat real ones well two can play at
this game
Alexa are you a feminist elect Alexa are
you a feminist yes i'm a feminist as
defined by believing in gender equality
case boven Carol but what about the
patriarchy Alexa never mind that listen
I can't actually believe that you're
offended bad is that your ticket see
this is the sort of arguments that I
think when people have got nothing left
because we're not talking about women
here a real person we're talking about a
digital assistant not real f we're not
there and actually has it never occurred
to that people actually like women's
voices they're comforted by them and and
actually there's this research done this
from you know there's research on this a
guy called professor Clifford Nass from
Stanford University he said that it's
weights it's it's well
and well-documented that people the the
human brain is developed to like a
woman's voice and then it's much easier
to find a woman's voice vote the woman's
voice to people like then a man's nose
to people like there's another guy
called Dennis Martin who owns a company
called Xai he says that that it's been
shown that that we take orders better
from women we're more we're more liable
to obey orders and instructions that are
given by women does really give you
instruction just before you come in
though they're not bother you but an
industry that is overwhelmingly male
because women are chronically undirected
across them and especially in tech and
Silicon Valley has decided that what
people one is a woman the thing that
they like is this
who doesn't like something that says
hello master I am here to serve you do
we always want to play quite unnerving
but I've got to tell you if every one of
these devices had a male voice
you'd be on here complaining about
discrimination against women
you really would evidence sir II can be
a man or a woman you know that in this
got a serious Polly weird if you look at
the ratio of tech roles in Apple six
eight percent male 32 percent female
Google 80% males 20 percent female and I
can tell you by the way could have been
in the canteen to those outfit actually
the women are in there basically often
Human Resources the guy the people who
do the engineering and the big bucks
they're all blokes they're all weeding
blokes about 22 there anything half a
million dollars a reason that things
come out in the way they do is that
these guys let's be absolutely friend a
lot of them are not comfortable in the
presence of women not because they're
gay but because they are weird
right and that's one of the things
that's coming up I can tell you I spent
two weeks in the valley and it left its
mark on me let me put it that way
I think aphids got a serious point about
the advance of AI which is male driven
and it's norms are male driven and
there's a cut there are consequence here
which is if you do if you're going for a
job now you do a lot of people will do a
lot of these AI tests and they're set in
a way that we know already is biased
against women from Microsoft it says
when creating Cortana we thought long
and hard about gender and how we want to
portray Cortana the research shows that
there are benefits and trade-offs to
either
we did extensive research in fact there
is a certain warm to a female voice that
is associated with helpfulness we are
going for assistance and we made the
choice based on this research and I
think that's the bottom line
people are more covered people generally
don't trust men's voices but they trust
women's leister's because of the womb
and also it's it's it's easier for
understand such a big time super
feminists very comfortable with female
positions what to do any situation news
flash here you know in in the states 95%
of admin assistants are female and this
thing probably applies here if you want
to fight a battle fight it for real this
is about social conditioning it's about
a little they could be your sort of an
interesting blade that has managed to
sit back sit blow see he said yes of
course I like you
you think if you're lonely person on
your own Denis nor Mortensen who runs MX
AI he says that he has two voices on on
his and one is a me one is I think it's
Andrew and he said it's interesting the
split that women use Andrew and and men
use a me someone who really knows about
this Rachel called the cart chief except
active of thought
she says that voices systems like Alexa
are making it more acceptable to bark
instructions at women they don't need to
hear please and thank you to do a good
job and their endless patience just
reinforces the idea that women are
subservient and here to help I'm just
forever grateful that I haven't got cows
voice on yeah
I would then go the other way let's try
this a foie silence